I'm it's worked oh hey that sounds like
I'm amplified wonderful so it's a real
pleasure to be here I really want to
thank the organizers I think it's it's
lovely to be part of this effort to
bring computational and experimental
people together so I'm gonna talk about
things that are very much echoing what
we heard from all of the previous
speakers with an emphasis on prospection
now I'd like to start my talk with this
slide just because it's fun to watch and
those of you have seen me talk before
I've seen this before
but for if you don't recognize that this
is from the movie ratatouille so here's
the food critic tasting the restaurants
ratatouille right from a neuroscience
perspective this is a sensory experience
and it drives this amazing mental time
travel back to his past where he
remembers his childhood you know he has
this relative you know obviously very
strong experience of the way he feels
the way his house looks all of these
things coming back to him and one of the
things that's really important about
this of course is that it happens
unbelievably quickly right and I think
this is successful from an artistic
perspective from my person from my
thought just because we can all relate
to this right we've always all had this
experience of having something just come
back to us in a flash but I also want to
emphasize that the purpose of memory we
assume from evolutionary perspective is
not that right reminiscing is probably
not that adaptive you know it's actually
a good way to get yourself eaten out on
this prairie what's really useful is to
the extent to which these memories allow
you to make better decisions in the
future all right and so I would say the
entire purpose of memory we think from
an evolutionary perspective is to be
able to use past experience to
extrapolate accurately into the future
so you can make good decisions right
simple things like oh we went to a nice
Vietnamese restaurant for lunch we could
go there again
or oh I ate there and got food poisoning
stay away from it right similarly you
are all here largely perhaps not
exclusively but largely to create
memories and if those of us here who are
speaking to you failed to create
memories in your heads then we have
failed at our duty and if you fail to
create memories then this is a waste of
your time right and we do that because
why our hope is that by telling you
scientific things or things they will
change the way you think and thereby
change your behavior all right so from
my perspective that's sort of the whole
point of these kinds of exercises at
some level and so we'd really like to
all I think all of us would like to
understand
how this works so if we're looking for
something that might constitute sort of
an element or a an event that
reactivates in a memory in the brain
what should we look for and so we can
generate sort of some hypotheses about
properties that it might have the first
of these is that it should be time
compressed all right when I remembered
what I did for lunch I did not spend an
hour reminiscing about standing in line
for 15 minutes ordering and so on right
that would be completely useless
memories are useful to the extent that
they take long extended experiences and
allow you to retrieve elements of them
very very quickly so that you can guide
decisions so if we're looking for this
in the brain ideally we might want
something that's time compressed also
this other issue is if we're right that
the whole point of this is to be able to
represent future possibilities or to be
able to extrapolate into the future then
we really should be looking for a
pattern of activity that's not just past
but also can be related to upcoming
decisions and then ideally we'd like it
to be related to those decisions and
we'd like to understand how do we go
from a memory structure where we think
about the past to a prospective
structure where we're actually starting
to think that they have things like
planning and imagination and can we come
up with some coherent story about how
all that might work so we record in the
hippocampus I think you know you've seen
lots of beautiful pictures from David
and you know other speakers of this this
is an example of hippocampal place cells
so hopefully this will just be fun to
watch but here we have a rat you can't
really see it but this is a w-shaped
track this is the activity of 46
simultaneously recorded cells you see
these beautiful
still there's a subset of cells in you
the location tivity is interrupted by
one of these events and that's a replay
like event as David mentioned and so
what we're trying to understand that
some level is how is it that we can
relate this sort of observation of
spiking activity to the functions of
this circuit now as many of you know who
are in the hippocampal field a lot of my
work is paralleled David's work focusing
on these sort of sharply ripple
sequences and I want to just touch on
that briefly because I then I'm going to
talk about something different which is
also parallel to what David is doing so
it's really a you know two-part thing so
again emphasize memories are presumably
there to allow experience to influence
upcoming decisions and you know based on
David's work and work in our lab we've
hypothesized that one role for the sharp
wave ripple events and David mentioned
this in the question period is to be
able to plan that is to be able to
generate trajectories that start where
the animal is in representational space
move away from the animal and therefore
allow the animal for example to evaluate
a value function should I go left should
I go right and that's the shark wave
ripples really look like they contain
activity that could do that
the problem is that perspective based on
these events would be limited to
behavioral states where these things are
seen and sharp wave ripples happen not
completely exclusively but almost
exclusively when the animal isn't moving
alright so if our hypothesis is that
these guys are what's supporting the
animals ability to plan then you get
this sort of you know uncomfortable
situation where as soon as the animal
starts trundling along it loses its
ability to think about the future right
that seems sort of unfortunate from a
behavioral and evolutionary standpoint
so we want to ask are there other forms
of non-local activity that could inform
decision-making processes and indeed
there another one and here I'm going to
borrow slides but not slides but figures
directly from David this is all work
done by a postdoc in my lab Kenny Kay
okay so you've seen this before now I'm
showing it again so this is from David's
lab of a series of play cells he showed
you this earlier and I'm stealing this
and I'm stealing more figures from him
because he's done a lot of the important
work on sort of establishing this
phenomena so he didn't talk too much
about this this is the theta rhythm so
this is this eight Hertz modulation of
activity that you see in the hippocampus
when animals wander
around and what they showed in this
paper is what you get on each size phase
of this data rhythm and again this is
actually work from a number of labs but
David's pictures are the nicest so I'm
showing those is you get the animals
actual position in gray here and you get
spiking sequences and we can do
something which we might call decoding
mental position which is we can ask
based on the firing properties of where
these cells are active what does it look
like the system is representing on each
phase of this cycle okay and it's been
known for a long time actually since
1996 when Bill Skaggs published this
first that later in the theta cycle you
get spikes from cells that are further
away from the animal and so what it
looks like on each cycle is this
beautiful sweep of activity starting
roughly where the animal is or a bit
behind and sweeping out in front of the
animal okay and that's happening about
eight times a second so from this
perspective place cells aren't placed
cells they're engaged in this sequence
which always has this little bit of sort
of temporal motion to it okay and then
again just finishing this up from
David's paper you can see that these
sequences actually go you know sometimes
as much as 50 or 60 centimeters into the
future if we sort of think of that
representationally but one of the
questions has been could these guys
actually represent possibilities or is
this just representing sort of maybe a
motor plan something the animal is going
to do we can ask that as a starting
point to that if we look at spiking
during these data sequences does it
fulfill some of the criteria that we're
trying to get at for something that
might involve something like memory so
the first point I want to make is it is
time compressed alright and I'll just
show you that again here each of these
sequences this is the real animals
motion the slope of this line is clearly
much steeper right and what's going on
there is that it's taking something that
occurs on a behavioral timescale from
you know this is one point five seconds
of running and each of these little
things is maybe two to four to six times
faster than that
so this is a time compressed
representation of some sort of movement
through space but is it capable of
representing future possibilities and
this is really what we wanted to ask is
there something in here that's more than
just a deterministic Here I am here's
where I'm going okay so I need to tell
you a little bit about the behavioral
tasks we use to explain what we're doing
here so this is this w-shaped track the
animal has to learn from trial and error
that the right sequence goes safer'
left to middle then it needs to remember
when it's in the middle arm that it came
from sorry yeah that is your left that's
right and then go to the right right to
middle and then again remember in the
middle arm that it needs to go to the
left
so those outbound trials require memory
of the previous choice right so we think
of those as a period we're planning is
required and we'd like to understand
what's going on when the animal comes up
to this point and makes a decision so
just for reference we're recording
throughout the hippocampus here but I'm
focusing here
well we're mostly looking at ca1 ca2 and
ca3 but the regions don't matter that
much except for one fly okay so let's
ask what do we expect to see based on
sort of our canonical understanding of
these events so let's imagine we have an
animal on a linear track here and these
are the representations of to place
fields where these cells are active so
we might see firing patterns like this
the green cell would fire first and then
the blue cell this is just standard play
cell graphing and if we then calculate
the cross correlation that is where the
spikes of the green cell fire come
relative to the spikes of the blue cell
we'd see that they mostly come to the
left right and that's just an
instantiation of those two firing reap
outs nothing interesting there but we'd
also see that on a shorter timescale say
about 500 milliseconds there's this
profound modulation based on the theta
rhythm and that's because on every cycle
while these two are overlapping the
green one will fire first and then the
blue one will tend to fire right and
it's not perfect but that's generally
true and so this is a real cross
correlation green blue green blue green
blue and this is what is the sort of
manifestation on a pairwise level of
that broader sort of sequential decoding
that David from David speakers okay so
this is what we expect to see this is
what we actually do see in some pairs of
cells alright so this is a little
complicated but here's the theta rhythm
and I hope you can see this these are
the place fields of the cells so this is
a firing rate heat map representing
where they're active in space on average
and this cell as you see is mostly
active on right-hand trajectories sorry
these are both outbound this one is
mostly active on left-hand trajectories
here the animal is running up towards
this choice point and you see that this
cell is firing on every other theta
cycle all right bump paws bump paws and
this actually is similar stuff that both
the Jim and Mike have shown in internal
cortex but I don't think it's been
documented in HIPPA cam
but correct me if I'm wrong maybe it has
figure at least okay sorry there is an
oaky figure on this I should have put
that up by that I didn't know thank you
okay and what you see what is I think
particularly exciting to us is that this
red cell is firing on every other
interleave cycle so it's red black red
black red black so this is one pass this
is the other pass all right so what we
have now is possibly sort of an
expansion of our representational
capacity now each cycle might have
something different going on okay so if
we look at this and we just asked what
do we see in the cross correlations of
these cells across all of the sort of 90
400 pairs of neurons that we have in our
data set about 66 percent of them
two-thirds do the canonical fire one
than the other in every theta cycle
thing about 8% of them are perfectly
anti synchronous all right so they fire
not at all together at time zero but
they fire quite often on every other
cycle about 16 percent of them are
perfectly synchronous on every other
cycle of theta so when one fires then
the next then they pause and fire
together and of course everyone can do
math the ones that we're not showing
here are kind of mixtures of these so
there's some intermediate cases and
really we think of this this is a
population level phenomena so even
looking at it in pairs isn't quite right
nonetheless I just want to show this to
indicate that it might be related to
behavior whoops and my battery is dying
so do we have another battery for this
anyway well it's just buzzing at me
yes pause that for a moment so will when
we get to the end we should talk about
what this might mean for if this is
related to decision making oh thanks
okay so until this dies so this is a
measure again adapted from both work
from Jim's lab and Mike's lab where
we're just measuring on single cells how
much do they tend to fire on every other
cycle this is not the best way to
capture this but the main point I want
to say is that this is while the animal
is moving so it's not that the animals
looking back and forth or anything it's
in ballistic motion and values of this
data skipping index greater than zero
indicate that it tends to fire more on
every other cycle and what you see is
that when the choices pass there's a
little bit of this but when the choice
is imminent there's actually quite a lot
more at both of these speeds so when the
animal is coming up to a bifurcation
where it needs to think about it we
assume we get more on a single cell
level of this theta skipping suggesting
that it might be related to upcoming
behavior or at least the representation
of future possibilities okay great so
what about at the population level
because that's where really this gets
interesting is is this really the
circuit oscillating in some interesting
way between you know different
representations so what I'm showing you
here this is the track this is sort of
in flipped over m shaped configuration
and the points here represent the animal
and head direction where the dot sort of
points at the animal's head from its
tail as it runs up and then smoothly
goes to the right this yellow area will
be highlighted on the next screen and
what we're going to do is we're going to
ask are there representations during
this period of either the left arm or
the right arm
okay so we're asking basically is the
animal thinking in some way about where
it's going and what is the temporal
structure of that thought now this is
complicated and I apologize in advance
there's a lot going on here but let me
just take you through it on the bottom
is the animal speed and the animals
angular head speed and the reason I'm
showing you that is that there's work
from particularly David radishes lab
talking about vicarious trial and error
where the animal looks one way and looks
the other and he sort of explored how
sequences might be generated there and
the point is just to say is this animal
is not jiggling its head back and forth
in any way that we can understand and
it's moving at quite high speed so this
is continuous smooth motion this is the
theta
this is that yellow period and what
we're using here is a cluster listt
coding method that we developed with our
colleague ory Eden the details don't
matter for this but the idea is we use
all of the spikes we record as well as
where they occurred in space to decode
on a one millisecond basis the sort of
instantaneous estimate of the population
representation of position happy to talk
about this in detail but that's for
questions and so what you're seeing here
this is the animals real position in
green this is the decoded estimate
alright and you see these nice sweeps
forward which is what we expect on each
data cycle and then when they get start
getting close to this choice point we
select something kind of cool from my
perspective so this is representations
of the right arm
this is representations at the left arm
so here it is it goes up into the left
next cycle up into the right left right
left right left and then it stays left
alright so this is the system
alternating at eight Hertz between what
looks like representations of future
possibilities until it seems to settle
on one and I would say I had no idea the
brain could do this I think it's kind of
neat to think about you know as one
makes one's own decisions about what
routes to take in life that's something
underlying like this might be going on
here's another example this is one where
the animal is a little bit more still
and its head is moving a little bit and
I'll just focus on this this is you know
left right left right left right left
right left right left and then right
alright this is hard to get my chance
all right and you can imagine all
quantify it in a moment but the main
point is here you know here the animal
is moving more slowly but there looks
like very very clear systematic
alternation and I'll say there's nothing
about alternation built into our
decoding model you know it only sort of
lives at a one millisecond time bin in
terms of its state space codes
transition so we can quantify how likely
is it that we would see this strength of
alternation I can just focus you on this
bottom plot this is three cycles or more
so left right left and the ones on the
red here this is negative log base ten
of the p-value so these are the ones
that are P less than 0.05 and eighty
percent of the time where we see more
than three cycles it's more less likely
to occur than chance when we shuffle the
order and resample it and in particular
I just want to emphasize there's this
huge ban out here which is just
incredibly like unlikely
so this is not happening all the time
but when it's happening it seems
extremely robust as far as we can tell
so here we're probably in this part of
the task so this is across all in
original learning and later but we're
probably averaging around 75 80 percent
correct so yeah yeah no they really they
still have to think which is you know
they're not fully automated from the
from the perspective of perfect or you
know 95% correct behavior okay the other
thing I want to emphasize oh sorry
supervisor unsupervised oh sorry so the
way the cluster listy coding works is
for all the spikes that occur while the
animals in motion we just collect them
up and so sorry briefly we do this for
each tetrode so we have four signals we
create a four dimensional amplitude
space in a one dimensional position
space and then for any spike we want to
decode we just look up its location in
the for the amplitude space and do a
kernel smoother on the 1d position space
and that's where we say it is so it's
based on the real data but we're not
using the data I mean it's based on the
data this gets complicated in terms of
which data goes into it but that's the
basic way it's constructed I hope that
answers the question okay and then the
point is here is most of these or a
large number of these the black points
in particular are occurring during
ballistic movement all right so we
really thought that the animal was just
you know representing Here I am where
I'm going this really suggests that the
stuff you know that David and others
have really been focusing on has this
extra representational capacity of
possibilities which is very exciting to
us okay so it is capable of representing
future possibilities as far as we can
tell right this is long before the
animal actually gets to that point and
is it related to behavioral decisions
which go a little bit to Peter's point
so I'm just gonna show you one example
of this what we're doing here is we're
building a decoding model where we
encode based on activity in these outer
arms alright so this is a little
different than what people in the place
field community have done we're not
looking at all an activity that has a
spatial bias on the center arm which is
called perspective and retrospective
coding we're just asking our cells that
are primarily active over here or over
here being active while the animals in
the middle arm so is it really that the
animal seems to be
thinking of places that are far away
from it either left or right and we
decode in every theta cycle and this is
actually important because this really
makes it look like the theta cycle is
the unit of consideration in this system
this is hard to see and I apologize but
this is say 400 or 50 or so trials over
a given day this is the actual choice
this is the probability all you can tell
from this is they oscillate together but
if you actually convert this into when
you get a leftward choice sorry right
we're choice in red what's the sort of
probability that you would have
extracted that from the sum of the theta
cycles as you can see these two are
almost perfectly non overlapping which
suggests that the system is representing
in a very accurate at least ensemble way
where the animal is going to go very
reliably now whether this reflects a
decision that's been made whether this
feeds into a decision that's going to be
made we have zero idea that's fun to
think about but this is what we know in
terms of the data and this is consistent
across all of our animals okay how am i
doing do I have a few more minutes okay
fantastic so this is then we think this
is actually related to behavioral
decisions but again the causality is
completely unclear so I want to now
switch to another kind of play cell
behavior which again David alluded to
because this is really almost like a
tag-team kind of thing here which is
directionality and just how do we think
about representation in the brain in
general particularly if we think that
some representation is of the here and
now and some representation has to do
with prediction all right and how do we
dissociate those and the nice thing
about the hippocampus is it from our
perspective it may be telling us how to
think about those so this is a standard
hippocampal place cell this is one
neuron and what you're looking at here
is all the firing the spikes when the
animal ends up going to the right and
all the spikes when the animal goes to
the left and that's just plotted here in
terms of firing great okay so we haven't
really looked closely at these least in
my lab so what you see first of all one
thing that's characteristic there is a
long tail here we think of that as the
future predictive activity this is when
the neuron is firing and maybe this is
when he's thinking about going left this
this blue activity might be and again
please don't take this too seriously
these are all hypotheses at this point
might be when the animal is here and
thinking about going left but actually
goes right right so if you think about
that theta alternation some cycles you
have the non actual representation
coming up so one interpretation of this
activity is not its own little place
field but is considering a possibility
that doesn't happen again
don't take this too seriously but just
work with me for the moment if that's
true then this activity should all occur
at late phases of the theta cycle which
is at the end of those sweeps right it
should all occur at the end of something
where the animals thinking future and
that is exactly what happens okay so
this is these are standard what are
called phase procession plots they're
slightly counterintuitive for this
purpose but this is late phase and this
is early phase so as the animal normally
traverses the place filled first spikes
come late phase that's when the act made
part of the activity is in front of the
animal and then that transitions to
earlier phase firing when the animals in
the middle of the place field and this
is you know this has been known for over
20 years the point is here we're not
getting a full cycle of this in the
other direction we're only getting the
part that we think might correspond to
something like a possible future alright
so it really looks like this theta phase
space might be allowing us to
distinguish between things that are more
present versus more future like okay so
this is just standard what about
directional activity so as David
mentioned cells often in a linear
environment fired differently in
different directions of motion they fire
more one way than the other so here's an
example where the non-preferred is this
one right and so this is an animal
coming up this way and there's some
spiking but it finds more in that same
location in the other direction right
you can see that from the firing rate
profiles here there's more in this
right-hand trajectory than back to the
left so how do we interpret this
directional firing is this just a little
place field or maybe and again I really
feel weird about saying this is this
maybe just maybe the animal thinking
that it could turn around okay
now if we're gonna entertain that for a
moment what would that mean well that
would mean that these spikes should
exclusively occur at late theta cycles
where we're thinking about something
future-oriented and that's in fact what
we see
all right and now it's not exclusive
this is a nice example but it's very
statistically clear and I can show you
the data from all of them that these
guys in the non preferred direction are
preferentially firing late that's data
cycle which is what we've been
associating with future whereas these
guys of course show that whole thing and
so maybe just maybe this is again that
same distinction and maybe we should
think about this sort of directional
firing as something where the system is
maintaining a representation of
possibilities at all times right and
from an adaptive point of view I think
it's really easy to see why that's
useful right it's nice to know that I
can turn around and go backwards right
it's nice to know it's likes to maintain
that representational capacity at all
times
so maybe this is what's going on here
okay is this even plausible right for
this to be plausible it needs to be
something that's true across the
population it can't be just one neuron
doing this at a time they need to be
doing it together
so the system needs to represent a
coherent possibility now everything I'm
showing you here is very hot off the
presses unfinished but here's a basic
idea here's a bunch of places on maps
where the cell prefers left and the
right word is in the light red here's
other cells where the prefers cell
prefers left these is the direction of
motion
mostly it's firing these black cells but
every once in a while you get three red
cells all firing together as though it's
a coherent representation of something
that is dominant in the opposite
direction and then finally just to
finish this up here's an example and I'm
just going to show this this is the
decoding of direction and what we are
seeing is left right left right left
right left right left and so on in this
every theta cycle the coding of which
way we would guess the animal is moving
from the spiking that we're seeing all
right now this is mostly on the late
phase of theta cycles this early phase
is a mess
right but again it's the same sort of
idea that these representations start
out where the animal is and then they go
to something or the you know the future
part can be all can be different than
where the animal is okay it's
significant I'm running out of time so
I'll stop so just in conclusion we find
frequent alternation much more frequent
than we'd expect by chance between
representations of what we look what
look like future possibilities across
data cycles it is not limited
- these vicarious trial-and-error
behaviors with the animal is doing this
this really seems to be something we can
see during directed motion which was a
huge surprise to us it seems to occur
for both divergent pass and opposite
directions of travel and you know based
on things that again Jim and Mike have
seen it may be something more general in
the brain for representing other kinds
of possibilities we don't know and then
we don't know what causal role this is
but it you know one can start telling
fun stories about evidence accumulation
you can imagine that if your brain can
imagine this one and then that one then
you could build up representations
inside of which is better and use those
to make a decision right alternately
this could just reflect some other area
telling the hippocampus we really don't
know okay lastly just to acknowledge
people Kenny as I mentioned who really
did this work and discovered this
phenomena
Jason Mari who contributed and Matias
who collected a chunk of the data and
worried our collaborator who helped us
or really to develop these algorithms
Thanks yeah we have not looked at
whether the first cycle is predictive
we've looked at on average if we just
count up the cycles
whether it's predictive but we don't
know yet it's a good question so just to
summarize what I'm gonna said so so do
the theta cycle in the early phases is
represented the places where the RIT has
been roughly where the animal is now so
early yeah we're sure the first part of
each data cycle cells are firing that
are roughly corresponding as far as we
can tell the current location late phase
give sort of possibility on every second
cycle to represent two alternatives
that's the idea yes yes right thank you
I really appreciate the maybe well so
this relates to Peters question so how
would the brain do this if it had
multiple options right you can imagine
all sorts of ways right you could
systemically alternate through three you
could do relative pairs or we could be
totally wrong right and something else
could be going on so I don't know which
of those it is it's appealing to me to
think that if this is a rhythm that is
basically clocking the local cycle of
processing in the brain then anything
you do has to be fit into that rhythm
and I think there's actually fairly
strong evidence for that in general so
then I would think that you might have
other area say okay left-right straight
straight you know something like that
and then maybe there's some sort of you
know decay mechanism whereby a
representation that's just been there is
gonna fall off and some else something
else will come up well we don't know yes
and that's it's that's seventy to a
hundred percent 99 percent correct
depending on which animal it is and how
good the data are so if you know if
basically you think it might be landing
on the station of performance you
mentioned your record during during
learning right at some point estas
becomes it yeah so we haven't quantified
this as a function of learning the
challenge is that this requires enough
data to be able to be really sure and
where we have enough data and the whole
learning cycle we haven't sort of tiled
that space sufficiently yet what I can
say at least is in these cases we're
talking about early enough in learning
that were fairly confident that a
hippocampal lesion would diminish
performance and we see this activity but
more broadly just because the
hippocampus isn't critical doesn't mean
it's not usually involved right so so
you know my own pet hypothesis is about
the utility is really that like how do
you even know that a bifurcation point
is coming up like if you're if you're on
a path how would you consider that how
would you represent that in a current
location so it
useful to have representations that
extend away from you and then you need
some way of regulating those in time so
that you don't get locked into one and
so maybe this is the brains way of doing
that to maintain behavioral flexibility
again I'm just making stuff up yes yes
so I wish we could do that we tried
decoding all possibilities and we don't
have the data to do that comfortably we
occasionally saw things that look like
there could be both directional and
future alternation but I do not feel
comfortable saying that and we see other
cells that we can't explain by either
direction or future thing doing this
alternation stuff so that maybe
representations of stuff that we don't
even know how to access but yes our
guess is that there may be others I just
can't prove that does this mean you end
up testifying more cells as being
directional because that would be what I
would yeah right that that would be the
so originally just for people's
reference on a completely novel track so
I'll start out largely equivalent in the
two directions of motion but within a
couple passes they start switching to
becoming strongly directional and so one
argument that could be made there is in
fact they become extremely directional
but the alternative firing we're just
misinterpreting as non directional it's
actually thinking about this other
possibility how do we prove that right
like how do you actually show that
that's what's going on I think it's hard
so this is that's why I was trying to be
so careful because I don't know how to
prove that right now but that's the idea
if you alternate though if you change
the reward contingencies in different
parts of the maze if you
could sort of get it that like it would
you expect to see like the instead of
the same ascent of an equivalent red
blue red blue would you produce the red
right so I mean it's interesting here
the animal knows what it's supposed to
do and is per paint behaving very well
and yet we're still seeing this
alternation right so on one hand the
alternation is predictive on the other
hand it's still there even though the
animals performing at high level so it's
certainly possible that we could bias it
more one way or the other and it's
possible on the cycles that we don't see
it we're just seeing a hundred percent
because the brain already knows which
way to go
so we need to I think introduce
different kinds of uncertainty and
planning to get at that exactly what
you're suggesting emergence of
directionality actually has a lot to do
with reward it's possible no one has
done this without reward that I know of
right which is sort of that related yeah
so so this is a problem right there oh
sorry they're roughly make sure I get
this right there's a circularity in the
way we evident where we do decoding and
estimate place fields and that we take
all of the spiking activity and we
assume that that defines a probability
distribution of spiking and what this is
suggesting is that that's wrong and that
there should be some parts of the
spiking particularly say the early phase
theta which is the real place field and
then there late phase theta shouldn't
even be in that in that case everything
will become stronger right because we've
gotten rid of all of those spikes that
are actually pulling the representation
back when we do the decoding we did not
do that here what extent do they corrupt
yeah so I would say you know let me just
go back for a moment so I just want to
show one place field so like this thing
right so there's a long tail here and
then the peak and so our our guess is
that in fact this is all corrupting and
something here is real and we don't know
where the transition is so from that
perspective you know yes it will change
things the amount it changes things I'm
not totally sure because we haven't done
that
[Applause]